[Music]
hey Amy add that pregnancy test though
false alarm it was just a big burrito
but that's not important right now okay
I'm in real trouble I was downstairs in
the lobby doing a bunch of shots with
these dentists at like a dentist's
convention anyway I think one of them
followed me up here
okay just lock your door that's the
thing I was like giving out copies of my
room key to people down there you don't
think it's a joke come up to my room
okay look hide under the bed you why
you're going to be taken no stay calm
shout out everything you see Rena we do
just hear used condom never bond that
okay so we're not gonna even celebrate
that I used a condom forget about the
condom I think I could reach us but
shouldn't punch his food no no don't
hello look I don't know what you want
but if this ransom Amy and I we did the
one movie together it's called a snatch
it comes out May 12 there's an
opportunity to promote our movie
snatched which comes out May 12 just in
time for Mother's Day also I have a
particular set of skills
hello room service guy have a law degree
this is not a kidnapper this is room
service art bringing me dinner options
miss Schumer left the note downstairs to
bring in her food wake her up if need be
right we just
understandable because in the Schumer
was in a blackout how bad was she one
side the tech I will not try to check
because I put all this food on your room
and I am NOT going to sign your name
because that is forgery
we're just words that is nothing good
nothing I'll show you worth the
kidnapping okay miss Delaine Oh daddy
maybe on the roof and get you taught you
text me
[Music]